It is time for hatred, mail. What is hatred?
EOT mail. This is hatred mail
[inaudible] Hey fine
Rand and Ronald Reagan had a baby and suckled
that child off the Tito of Liberty. It's cries
would sound a little [inaudible]. The thing
like, Hey, tread written by Patriots. Who
hate David Pakman because America and because
freedom.
All right, this week's, Hey, treat mail. It's
sort of a linguistic misunderstanding of sorts,
I guess. Maybe, or maybe it's just plain old
antisemitism. Take a listen.
Jesus Christ. Dude, Hillary's not coming back.
It's been almost two, three years. She lost.
Trump won. David Pakman is such a fall and
flop and sore loser. What a pathetic loser.
Pop out your 10 foil hats folks. Pacman is
going full reread and park man is a wait for
it. Oscar not see.
Yeah, this is something you see many times.
There's people who see Ashkenazi and see that
in there. The word Nazi is in there like national
socialist from, you know, the, the third Reich.
And they say, ah, there's just like a misunderstanding
about the etymology of these words. I believe
that the word Ashkenazi, um, goes back to,
uh, the grandson of a, I believe it's Japan
in the old Testament, one of the sons of Noah,
something like that. I mean, I don't really
know too much about the Bible, but there's
like some, some word that that comes from.
And then Nazi is I believe, a contraction
for national socialists. And I think that
it's just a coincidence. I don't know that
there's anything more to Ashkenazi containing
NAZ. I, unless I'm misinformed, but in any
case, I'm not sure that this hatred was really
doing a linguistic analysis.
I think it was just a old fashioned antisemitism.
But what you can do to fight hatred, autism
in your community is to use the coupon code
hatred@fortywhenyousignupforamembershipatjoinpacman.com
that coupon code saves you 40% and it says,
no, no, no to the hatred IOTs, they will not
succeed. The spelling of the coupon code is
H a T R I O T for zero.